[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone so in this video
I'm going to give a really high level
tutorial about how to use Matlab for
scientific Computing and Engineering so
this is just a super quick and dirty
Intro by no means extensive but it'll
get you started on some of the basic
things you need to you know do Matrix
Vector multiplications or you know plot
your data simulate an ordinary
differential equation things like that
this is uh from a code written by Scott
Wilcox when he was a TA for my me564
class and so this is just going to
follow kind of this tutorial code here
and I'm more or less just going to walk
you through
um through these things so this is kind
of like a prerequisite just like I
assume you know you know calculus and
Taylor series I'm going to hope that you
kind of feel pretty comfortable with
using these basic uh kind of Matlab
functions so that you can play around
with your data plot things analyze you
know your data and your functions as you
follow along in these various courses
and again more advanced stuff we'll
cover as needed you know I'll have lots
of lectures where all we do is derive
runga Cutta integrators and show how to
do that in Matlab or in Python this is
really just kind of the very high level
quick overview so I'm going to jump in
um
at the so so first off in Matlab I
usually use scripts these dot m files
instead of working in the command line
command line you know command by command
I usually write a script so I can run
all of the script at once or I can run
these cells which are separated by a
percentage percentage so you can kind of
run each cell independently one after
the other if you like that's kind of how
I like to do it and before at the
Preamble of all of my scripts I usually
clear all close all and CLC which means
I clear all the memory I close all the
windows and I clear the command window I
clear all this junk here so let me just
do that
um okay so I ran that it cleared all of
my
memory closed everything cleared for
some reason it looks like there is still
stuff in memory but I'm pretty sure
that's not true I think if I type beta
yeah it's like DT so clear all close all
CLC and it clears the command window
okay so basic operations you can do
things like add subtract multiply divide
just like you would expect you know
asterisks is times uh backslash is or
sorry forward slash is um is divide and
then order of operations are the way
that you learned in in grade school so
two minus two times seven Matlab is
going to interpret this as multiply two
by seven first and then subtract that
from two or if you like you can put in
parentheses if you want to explicitly
make one of these operations uh be done
first
you can assign variables so I can I can
say the a variable is 2 plus 2. and
notice I put a semicolon here if I don't
put a semicolon here Matlab will output
that line of code the output of that
line of code so if I run this oops
if I run this uh you'll notice that it's
actually outputting two plus two two
times two two divided by 2 2 minus 2
times 7 and 2 minus 2 quantity times
seven so if I don't specify then Matlab
is going to Output everything every line
that does a computation it's going to
Output the end of that computation and
so here if I remove my semicolon from
this it will also output at the very
last output a equals 4. so oftentimes
you'll put semicolons around things this
is called suppressing the output the
default is that Matlab is going to spit
everything out to the screen so that you
can see what is being computed in real
time
okay that's the basic operations what
about loops okay so you want to be able
to do for loops and while loops and
things like that so pretty easy
um
in Matlab to create a loop for example
in this example we're going to count all
of the numbers we're going to add all
the numbers up from 1 to 10. so we're
going to basically make a loop that
Loops through all of the numbers from 1
to 10 all the integers from 1 to 10 and
adds those integers to my counter so I'm
going to start by initializing my
counter equal to zero
then in this 4 I I equals 1 to 10 what
that literally does is it one that one
colon ten creates a vector from one to
ten in increments of one so if I do this
it spits out this this Vector one to ten
and so for I I equals one to ten it
literally is going to go through every
element of this Vector for I I equals
one for I I equals two for I I equals
three four five and for each of those
it's going to add that that that I I
that number to my counter so my counter
is going to be growing and we put a
semicolon here so it suppresses the
output
uh and I can run this code
okay so we ran this code and then count
is as you would expect the sum of the
first 10 integers is 55. okay we know we
know that that's 55.
um
if I wanted to Output the count at each
step I would just remove this semicolon
and run this and now you see the count
growing
um you know so the count
after I I equals one my count was
um was one then I add two and it becomes
three then I add three sorry I need to
find my cursor I had three and it
becomes six I had four and it becomes
ten five and it becomes fifteen six add
six it becomes 21 28 36 and so on and
you get the picture okay so you can
output
um at every step here if you if you
suppress if you don't suppress that
output with a semicolon good okay so
that's easy easy easy to write these
four loops and again it's based on this
uh this construction here that one colon
ten creates a big Vector from one to ten
in increments of one
I could also have said one colon one
colon ten and this explicitly says I
want a vector from 1 to 10 with
increments of one
if I wanted to I could also make this so
that'll give the same thing
and if I want to change my increment
maybe I want uh I want a vector from 2
to 10 in increments of two
I say 2 colon two comma colon 10 and it
gives me a vector from 2 to 10 in
increments of two I could do a vector 2
to 10 in increments of three and it's
going to be you know 2 5 8 and there's
not an exact number of Threes between
two and ten so it's going to stop at
eight and so you can create these
vectors any way you like I could create
a vector from one to five in increments
of point one
so it'll be um
kind of a big thing uh you know one 1.1
1.2 1.3 1.4 1.5 all the way up to to
five okay so you can do this
um and you can do four II equals any of
those constructions and it's going to
run what's inside this for Loop for
every single element of that set or that
Vector that's constructed so that's
really really useful
if you want your your numbers if you
want something like pi
we know that Pi is not 3.1416 it has
more decimals it has infinitely many
decimals if I type format long and then
I type Pi it'll give me 16 and the the
full double double float Precision
number so it'll actually spit out more
stuff here which is kind of cool and if
I do format short
it'll go back to my simple you know
compact decimal representation
aisle Loops so let's say I set my
counter equal to count so it starts at
55 because I've just added them all up
from one to ten so counter is 55 and
we're going to write a while loop so
that while my counter is bigger than 10
I'm going to subtract 1 from the counter
and so presumably this will subtract
until counter is exactly equal to 10
because that's not bigger than 10 and
this condition will be violated
so I'm going to run that
and of course now counter
I've subtracted one so many times until
counter was no longer greater than 10
it's in fact equal to 10 that's not
greater than 10. if I said while counter
is greater than or equal to 10
it'll have to subtract one more until
counter is nine so I think that'll
happen if I do this
and counter is nine so so you can do
greater than or greater than or equal to
pretty pretty easy and your while loops
and for loops
okay now let's create vectors and
matrices super super easy and intuitive
in Matlab so we can create a vector
so there's a few ways of creating a
vector actually a underscore Vector you
can use brackets and then spaces one two
three four creates a vector I'm just
going to like copy this into the command
line so you can see it literally creates
a row Vector one two three four we can
do size of a vector and it'll tell us
that it's a one by four Vector it's
literally a row Vector with one row and
four columns
um if I do a underscore Vector
apostrophe it'll turn that into a column
vector and so if I do size of that
apostrophe Vector it should be a four by
one column Vector pretty useful I could
also Define that I could say a vector
equals if I didn't want so I defined it
as a row Vector one two three four like
that
if I want it to be a column Vector I
just put semicolons between all of those
entries semicolon semicolon semicolon in
Matlab semicolon is what tells it that
you're starting a new row so I can
create a vector like that and it creates
a column Vector so you can create row
vectors and column vectors very easily
um you can create a vector of ones super
easily just using the ones command ones
of one comma four creates a row Vector
of ones if I did ones of four comma one
it would create a column Vector of ones
no big deal
and you can create a matrix in the same
way so this creates a matrix by
essentially stacking two rows
let's see if this works
um
okay it creates it here I would have put
a semicolon I always put semicolons like
that I think that's really important for
me visually to understand that those are
two rows that are separated you know
like the semicolon says I'm starting a
new row and you could have even if you
liked Define this in the following way
you could have said well I'm going to
Define this as of an array
of arrays like this I'm pretty sure this
is also going to work in Matlab I hope
it works and then size of a matrix
should be a two by four array so you
know and I could have put square
brackets around every single one of
these numbers and Matlab will know you
know oh those are stacked in a row
vector and then two row vectors on top
of each other forms this Matrix so
pretty flexible how you define these
things and you can access the elements
pretty easily so I could say you know a
vector of one is going to give me the
first element of that a vector of 2 is
going to give me the second element of
that Vector if I do a matrix of one
comma one it'll give me the the first
entry
if I do it of 2 comma 1 it'll give me
the First Column of the second row so
it's row then column so it should be
five
if I want the whole First Column I can
do that too I say a matrix of colon
comma one this will be the first whole
column the First Column so the the one
five column if I did colon comma two
it'll be the second column uh colon
comma three is the third column if I
want the whole first row I would just do
one comma colon so again I want the
first row all of the columns that's how
you do this in Matlab so really easy to
pull out different sub pieces let's say
I want the first two by two block
I would just say a underscore Matrix of
I want the first two by two so I could
do one colon two comma one colon two
that's you know I basically create a
vector of indices for the rows and for
the columns from one to two and one to
two and I can pull out that Vector if I
want the middle sorry sorry I can pull
out that Matrix if I want the middle two
by two Matrix I would do the same thing
but instead of index columns one to two
I would do columns two to three and
that's the the middle two by two
um sub Matrix of a so really easy to
pull these things out and work with
these and analyze these and multiplying
to multiply our matrix by a vector the
sizes and shapes have to work out so if
I multiply a you know two by four Matrix
let's call it one two three four five
six seven eight that's my Matrix if I
want to multiply this by a vector that
Vector head better be a column Vector of
size four by something four by one so
one two three four because this is the
only Dimension that makes sense for a
matrix Vector multiplication in Matlab I
couldn't do this Matrix times a row
Vector I'd have to do this Matrix times
a column vector
um
and so here you'll notice we defined our
a vector up here to be a row vector
and so here when I want to do my Matrix
times that Vector I have to transpose it
using that little apostrophe I told you
about and if I do that
let me just see what a vector is in case
I overwrote it on accidents okay here I
overwrote it into a column Vector so I
can just do a matrix times a vector
because here a vector is already a
column vector and that'll give the two
by one Matrix after multiplying this
Matrix Vector product if I defined a to
be a row vector
like up here so now a is a row vector
then a matrix times a vector
is going to give me an error because I
can't multiply this matrix by a row
Vector it won't work so I'd have to take
and transpose that vector and now it's
going to be totally fine so this can be
a little finicky at first trying to get
all these Dimensions to work but you'll
get the hang of it like if you if you do
if you practice this at all you'll get
the hang of how to make these things
work out with transposes
okay good
um
you can do things like element wise uh
operations like I can square every
element of the a matrix by doing Dot to
the second power so in Matlab generally
speaking any array like an array a if I
do dot to the second power it's going to
square every element one by one so it'll
give me a matrix one four uh 9 16 25 36
and so on and so forth so you know if I
run this it should give me that square
the element wise square of the Matrix
okay I'll point out you can download
this.m file and follow along and play
with it and change it yourself and this
is all uploaded links in the description
below
okay good now we might want to create a
vector of time and do things like plot
functions of time and create functions
of time so here again I already showed
you how to do that colon operation so
this is going to create a vector from
minus 100 to 100 in increments of one so
minus 100 minus 99 minus 98.
minus 2 minus one zero one two dot dot
dot 98 99 100 a big vector
and that's our the time Vector you could
just call it t I don't know why we call
it the time uh it's just you know t
and then I can create functions of time
so this first function F1 is t squared
times sine of T and my second function
is t squared and remember this dot
squared is going to element wise Square
it so that it's a vector of that instant
in time squared times sine that instant
so to some extent if I have this T
vector and if I think of it as being you
know time one time two times three dot
dot
then what this uh in line 72
writing T dot squared is going to create
a vector of T1 squared T2 squared T3
squared dot dot dot okay and so this
allows me to plot
these functions versus time Point by
Point okay so this will be kind of nice
and then we can plot these things let's
run this
oh and then the plotting is already here
so you can create a figure and you can
specify which figure number so I'm
creating the 40th figure for some reason
if you don't give it an argument it'll
just create a new figure
and we're plotting T by F1 we're going
to plot it as a red line with line with
two meaning it's it's got a thickness of
two and hold on if I want to plot two
plots on top of each other I have to use
this hold on or else the second plot
will overwrite the first plot and I
won't be able to see them on top of each
other
so this holds everything on the current
plot so the first plot is this F1 t
squared sine of T and the second plot F2
is just t squared and we're going to
plot this one in a black dashed line of
line with two I'm inverting the color
screen on my
the color scheme on my laptop so that it
looks good on this black background so
this red is actually going to look cyan
and this K black is actually going to
look white but in at home these will be
the right colors
and these plots you can add labels to
the plot I'm going to run this
I can add labels to the plot
I can add Legends to the plots I can add
a grid title notice how it's teeny tiny
so I'm going to show you live that I can
say set GCA that's the get the current
Graphics axis so set the current
Graphics axis
and I'm going to set the font size to be
24
so automatically that's going to make it
look way way better and then I'm also
going to set the position set the the
position of my figure
so each of these so there's the graphics
sorry there is the axes which have
things like the labels and things like
that and then there's the figure which
has properties like the position of the
figure and you'll have to get used to
you know what is an axis property and
what's a figure property but I can also
change the position uh to something like
1500 pixels by 500 pixels so it's going
to go over on my screen 1500 pixels and
up 500 and then I can set the width and
height to be 800 pixels by 800 pixels
and if I run this it'll run it over here
and give me this nice plot that's a
little bit bigger with these bigger axis
labels so lots of nice things you can do
just
like that I'm pretty sure that the set
command has a dual which is called the
get command so I think if I do like get
GCA it'll spit out all of the properties
of this current Graphics axis so these
are all the things you can change on the
axes of your plot you can change the the
tick direction from going in to out you
can change the tick length or you know
the projection to orthographic there's
all these properties that you can find
using get and for every one of these
properties in get you can set them to
different values and so you can very
much customize the the plots the the
plots and so GCA and GCF are the two
kind of main things that are the axes
and then the figure itself
plotting is really easy in Matlab that's
one of the things I like about it is
that it's easy to play around with your
data you run some calculations and you
can dump uh you know you can look at
your Matrix and you can query your
Matrix you can plot your things really
really easily really really quickly in
Matlab as a general rule okay my plot
was too tall so I'm going to make it
shorter as a general rule you know
always put axis labels on your plots you
know if you want to look smart and
you're presenting data label your axes
and put a legend on always helps when
you're communicating
okay good what else do I want to show
you uh linear systems is really
important so solving linear systems of
equations like
um if I have a matrix a and a vector two
vectors X and B I'm going to just erase
this
um
if I have
a x equals b as a matrix system of
equation so a is a matrix and x and B
are vectors let's say that I know a and
I know B and so I'm solving for x so
solve for
X that's something that's really really
easy to do in Matlab so here we're going
to create two Matrix a and a vector B
corresponding to this system of
equations here
you can convince yourself that this a
matrix and this B correspond to this
system of equations and solving for x is
like trivial and Matlab it's just a
backslash B so the backslash command is
one of the nice things in Matlab it's
really easy to solve for x that
satisfies this equation and what's cool
about this is that this will solve even
when a is not a square Matrix so if a is
a square Matrix and is invertible this
will find you know inverse of a times B
the exact solution but maybe a is a big
you know over determined Matrix and
there's many many more systems of
equations than there are unknowns so a
is a tall skinny Matrix
or maybe it's an underdetermined Matrix
a short fat Matrix in those cases it'll
find the x that best satisfies this in
the least squares sense so even if
there's not an exact solution X it'll
find an X so that a x minus B has a
minimum two Norm or so that X has the
length of X has a minimum of two numbers
those are the least squares Solutions
and matlab's pretty clever about finding
the best way of solving a backslash B
depending on the shape of a and
properties of A and B so really nice
kind of built-in command here and you
could compare this against you know in
of a times B that will give you the same
answer for the square Matrix a
okay and that'll also work even for a
very very large system maybe I'll do one
thing first I'm just going to run this
okay so it gave a b and x and you could
confirm that a times x
minus B is in fact the zero zero Vector
okay so that shows that it found the x
that actually solves this you can also
create really big random matrices this
can be useful for testing algorithms if
you want to test it on a bunch of
matrices using this Rand and command so
Rand and creates if you give it two
variables Rand and 100 by 100 this will
create a hundred by hundred Matrix where
each entry is a normally distributed
random variable mean zero unit variance
Rand and returns it basically samples
from a gaussian normal distribution and
it'll generate a matrix with 100 by 100
elements each with a zero mean unit
variance gaussian random variable I can
make a vector of size 100 by one so a
column Vector also with these Rand ends
these normally distributed random
variables if I deleted the N it would
instead of creating a gaussian random
variable it would create a uniform
random variable on the uniform interval
zero to one okay so you can do both of
those and again you can solve these very
large systems of equations with the
backslash and this is that big X that
comes out of that solution
okay another thing I want to show you is
how to simulate ordinary differential
equations like let's say I want to
simulate uh
x dot equals f of x with some initial
condition X naught we can simulate those
in Matlab using some powerful built-in
numerical integrators like the runga cut
a fourth order scheme so pretty simple
this is the ode45 command is the
all-purpose fourth order runga
integrator there's many others there's
ode like 1 1s for a stiff scheme they're
a one one two s there's
ode two three there's a bunch of ode
schemes for stiff systems for stochastic
systems this is a good general purpose
for you know a generic system you should
start with this
and od45 is expecting a certain number
of input parameters it's expecting a
function
I called it ode test here or
um Scott did it can be named anything
you want but it's basically a function
that encodes this right hand side of
your differential equation
so in my environment
um
here there's actually this ode test.m
file which if you open that it is a
function that Returns the derivative DX
so so the the differential equation I've
written down is a two-state differential
equation so technically it's um
you know X1 Dot and X2 Dot equals and I
think X One Dot equals X2 and X2 dot
equals minus Lambda
X1 minus Zeta X2 that's the differential
equation we're going to simulate and so
this basically computes some stuff and
then it returns this x which is I would
call this DX if I was writing this code
this would be for me DX DT
and this would be DX dt1 and DX
dt2 that's totally fine and so as long
as this function
Returns the right hand side of your
differential equation that's what
matlab's ode45 is expecting a function
that encodes the right hand side of your
differential equation it's expecting
this function may vary in time and in
space in T and in X
um there's no reason this has to be
called
X not so I'm just going to remove that
there's also no reason to do this
I'm just trying to clean this code up a
little bit
um
so
OD 45 expects a function a right hand
side Vector field this f of x it expects
that it might change in time it might be
a function of T comma X so in general
this could encode dynamics that actually
change in time so it's like T comma X
you'll notice that my Vector field my
right hand side function doesn't change
in time and if it doesn't change in time
it just won't have any T variables
that's fine but Matlab still expects the
function to be defined so that it could
take in a t comma X
because it's oda45 is basically going to
wrap around this ode and evaluate it a
bunch of times and so it needs to know
how to plug in different T's and x's and
get the outputs to do its internal
algorithm
so if I go back to my intro code here
ode45 takes in that ode test that that
right hand side function it takes in a
time span which is uh literally a start
time and an end time this could also be
a vector I could tell it what increments
to sample I could say the time span is 0
to 10. uh in increments of 0.01 that's
fine I can do that too and it needs an X
initial condition it needs this x naught
which in this case is a vector because
my system is a vector system of
differential equations
and that's super easy like this od45
basically codes up one of the most
powerful all-purpose integrators the
fourth order runga Cutta scheme and
it'll run on almost any right hand side
Vector field you can you can plug into
here this will simulate that system and
it's going to Output the time points
that it computed and the output of the
state y out which is going to be an
array
of X1 and X2 at all of these instances
of time so I'm going to run this
um I'm pretty sure I need to set my GCA
to font size 24 so it doesn't look
terrible and I'm going to plot things
with a line width of let's say three
just so it looks good
oh no
what happened OD test must return a
column Vector I messed up
I got too much hubris I flew too close
to the sun when uh when Scott defined
this DX DT and pre-allocated that he
pre-allocated as a vector
a column Vector so I think
I'm going to say column one column two
so I'm making sure that DX DT is a
column Vector this should work now
and let's try this again okay good it
didn't crap out this time
uh set GCA font size 24
okay it's having issues I'm having a lot
of issues today uh my Legend there's an
error in my Legend
uh error setting property position of
class Legend okay maybe I won't move my
Legend
let's not do that
um
I also don't like titles to be honest
with you
um
let's try this
oh yeah okay here's the problem
um
let me get rid of this I'm just going to
comment all of this out for now
and here now this looks better okay so
here what we've done is we've plotted
um
T out comma y out so it plots this y out
as a function of time and Y out has size
let's let's look at the size of Y out
y out was the output of my runga cutter
integrator and its size 1001 by 2. so
this is actually a huge two column
Matrix which is weird because I think of
my state as being a column Vector but it
gives me this big you know a thousand
entries in time for X1 and for X2
and so when I plot T out by y out it's
basically going to plot you know the
first column in one color and the second
column and another color I think the
First Column corresponded to position
and the second column corresponding to
velocity of a system and so if I run
this and maybe I can keep my Legend uh
this time it's really not liking my
Legend
um
there must be Legend uh I think maybe I
want an array
of Legends let's try this
yeah that's better no that's not better
uh position
comma velocity this is not going to work
okay if I wanted I would say help Legend
and it would tell me how I messed up my
Legend
um
let's see there are two variables here
yeah this really should work position
and velocity
[Music]
um
oh I'm sorry this is stupid
um
Legend has a property called its
position I can move that Legend to the
upper left or to the upper right or to
the lower left or the lower right and so
this I here I meant position and
velocity but it's thinking I'm trying to
overwrite the position variable with
something called velocity this is this
is confusing let's say position comma X
and velocity comma V this should work
and now it doesn't have a problem okay
so that's stupid
um
anyway this is my plot it looks really
nice and it plots those two positions
and velocities the output from my ode
integrator so really really powerful
stuff the the headline here is that you
can do ode integration of almost any
Vector field even if it changes in time
even if it's high dimensional it can
have 100 States it could be very
non-linear you can solve it using od45
and you can plot and analyze the results
uh using your plotting techniques
um that's pretty much everything I
wanted to tell you there's also some
code in here to animate your plots which
is cool so you can make movies which
look really nice
um you know so essentially we're going
to
um you know for I for J equals one to
the length of a movie we're going to
plot some stuff and using this get frame
it's going to take whatever that plot
was and create a frame in a movie and
then when you're done with that for Loop
you can run the movie command on all of
those frames and it'll Stitch those
together really really easy and
hopefully this works
uh
you can't see it here because it's so
faint but you can see this little sign
you know this little function is being
curved out and it's going to create this
movie uh once once it's made all of
these frames and then you can do things
like actually save this movie to an MPEG
or an avi file or a DOT movie file and
and or a gif whatever you like okay
good so that's really the high level
overview of just quick and dirty Matlab
this is by no means everything but this
will give you a good basis to start
things like how to build a matrix how to
build a vector how to multiply them how
to solve The Matrix system of equations
how to write down a vector field and
integrate it and plot you know that's
most of what you're going to do anything
more advanced we're going to build from
scratch so in a lot of my videos You'll
see there's Matlab and python code where
we use these basic commands to build up
more complicated functions and we use
other more complicated built-in commands
but this gives you at least you know
most of what you need to get started to
kind of code up your own stuff to play
around with your data and to plot things
like that all right thank you
[Music]
foreign